the last time I spoke to Shane was at a
Jeffree Star skin event she like eight
months ago and it's it's interesting
because Shane was my idol Shane was my
world he saved my life and he saved your
life how did you save your life in so
many ways really but it it began with
like I fell in love with the idea of him
and his sense of humor as well him
joking about up obviously that
didn't age well but I'm saying at the
time to make light of trauma and to
provide an escape for people who might
need it and I was that person who needed
it you know my household's full-blown
chaos awful I'm crying I hate my life
and for five minutes of a day I get to
escape in Shane Dawson's day gets to
make me laugh at the time he he was so
there for me day in and day out and like
mentored out of me I'm like how to
deal with all of the emotions of this
lifestyle and so it was hard for me when
he got canceled like I I was sad people
always say you like live long enough to
see your Heroes become like villains in
a regard and that's what it felt like
for sure and then it has you kind of
second guessing everything